[Música]
cómo es tu ipad tomas tu smartphone y
entras a la plataforma de noticias que
tú prefieres y te encuentras con una
terrible pero terrible noticia joven
pareja mueren
por causa de amor
las circunstancias un suicido
y toda la ciudad se estremece de todo
menos estremece porque eran muy
populares y tú sacaste tu foto en
facebook con mensajes con tu amigo y la
chava sacan su foto donde salen con su
amiga y las dos familias que eran
familias rivales pues a fin de cuentas
se reúnen y recogen los cuerpos y están
los vídeos en vivo y las transmisiones y
la personas que siguen las
investigaciones y sigue en las redes
sociales esta historia de un suicidio
por amor y convencida en la historia
resulta que sigue des investigación de
civiles se les empieza a aparecer la
historia de un fraile
y el frío y leves resulta que es acusado
por la procuraduría porque es un
homicidio puntos y extenso defensa dice
es que me puede enviar el whatsapp ella
se llamaba julieta él se llamaba romero
y el fraile no puede mandar su whatsapp
no hay madre porque te pueda suceder lo
que nos pueda suceder que quedarnos sin
pila en nuestros celulares
y más como está a punto de enviar un
mensaje que puede salvar una vida o que
puede destrozar o romper un corazón o
aliviar un corazón o incluso lanzar un
tweet que pueda cambiar el mundo
diciendo que hay paz en nuestros móviles
hoy en día se vuelve algo casi casi como
una extensión de nuestras de nuestras
nuestro cuerpo y tengo es darwin pudo
haber dicho que era una extensión
adicional a nosotros y vemos al último
que está casi casi muriéndose pero todo
nace por una sola por un solo elemento
que se llama energía
la primera lección que yo tuve sobre
cuidado del medio ambiente tuvo que ver
con esa como apaga el foco no fue lo
primero que me dijo mi mamá tienes que
apagar los focos cuando sales del cuarto
porque hay que cuidar necesarias y el
bolsillo realmente o la energía no
y la biblioteca en la primaria pues
existían estos topos que solamente
aparte de iluminar amarillo como la casa
de los abuelitos iluminaban no solamente
amarillo pues a pagar te provocaba y
generaba calor
y después de esto lo más interesante que
tuve acerca no también con el cuidado
del medio ambiente tenía que ver con
bañarme rápido y una época de mi vida en
la universidad que estuve en una escuela
que me enseñaron a bañarme en tres
minutos quienes creen que no es posible
si se puede bañarse en tres minutos
hasta el menos y engañado nuevo año
vaquero y mañana
el otro que sucedió es que una vez
prendida televisión algunos a veces
están riendo porque es la primaria me
tocó ver una campaña la primer campaña
masiva de cuidado del medio ambiente
donde aparecía este personaje simpático
gordito mexicano a morenito cuerpo de
uva
que decían ser no mucho
y aparecía la señora queriendo lavar el
carro y le decía cierre luego de repente
ciclado con el auto enjabonado iglesia
cierra le dio la primera campaña que yo
veía en medios masivos que hablaba
acerca del cuidado del medio ambiente y
de cuidar un recurso natural cuando
llegué a la preparatoria
tuve una materia que se llamaba ecología
y una materia muy extraña porque
realmente nunca había escuchado en la
primaria ni en la secundaria acerca de
esta palabra y poco a poco se empezaba a
ser común y el maestro se explicaba
muchas cosas acerca del medio ambiente y
el encuentro más cercano que tenía con
la naturaleza era mi experiencia cuando
había sido boy scout yo sé que ya tienen
las imágenes sus mentes calcetas hasta
que arriba
georges hasta acá camisa gris una cosa
enredada acá en el cuello
y mi casa más
y la verdad que me empezó a llamar mucho
la atención la carrera de ecología y me
parecía como algo fascinante y como que
el mundo necesitaba nuevos héroes y no
propiamente va a necesitar alguien que
le gustará la contaduría y las finanzas
sino que necesitaban nuevos héroes y
después de haber sido durante muchos
años way scout y andar con el paño de
pintar con mis short y haciendo el
ridículo cuando me subía a la ruta a la
pecera
lo más divertido era que podía tener
contacto con la naturaleza
pero el mundo te presiona y depresiones
demasiado y al final me quedé con cuatro
opciones como con cuatro paletas de
verano que si no te lavas acaba rápido
se te derriten te que han embarrado los
dedos tenía que decidir rápidamente
porque no solamente te presiona la
sociedad te presionan tus papás te
presionan las escuelas que están ya me
llaman cada rato mandando cartas en esa
época para que decidas por ellos o
decidas una carrera y me quedo con
cuatro opciones y esas cuatro opciones
eran contaduría y finanzas la otra de
administración la otra de mercadotecnia
y la otra a er ecología y la a fin de
cuentas terminé estudiando mercadotecnia
dentro de ecología y mercadotecnia me
quedé con mercadotecnia y se convirtió
en la paleta de mi vida
han pasado 23 años desde que tuve mi
clase de ecología y medio ambiente y han
pasado 16 años desde que decidí estudiar
mercadotecnia y hoy que vivo en
tamaulipas que tengo ya muchos años
viviendo en tamaulipas en pausas he ido
y he regresado no estoy en una región en
la cual tiene un destino por así decirlo
trazado estamos destinados a hacer la
capital energética de méxico estamos
destinados o estamos llamados a generar
el 31 por ciento de la energía eléctrica
que necesita este país para funcionar
día con día
pero al mismo tiempo también tenemos que
reconocer que esto esté convertidos en
la capital energética del país incluye
una serie de decisiones que debemos de
tomar como colectivo porque les platiqué
lo de la preparatoria porque tiene mucho
que ver con la educación y esta
educación nos va a llevar a un parque
eólico por ejemplo el que ya tenemos en
el centro del estado que tiene una
inversión proyectada y el que está aquí
cerca en reynosa de 750 millones de
dólares es implica trabajo es implica
dedicación
eso implica negocios es implica dinero
para las personas que no han visto
productiva sus tierras es implica nuevos
empleos es implica tecnología es implica
innovación y eso implica también
migración aunque quiera medir a comer
frijoles o no quieran venir a comer
frijoles
en la década de los 80 es casi finales
de los 70s
hubo un auge petrolero en la tierra de
los olmecas no sólo la tierra de los
olmecas dejó de ser la tierra del
pantano y se convirtió en una tierra que
proyectaba riqueza que no se iba a
acabar y le era una riqueza a través del
petróleo y dentro de esa de esa vorágine
de riqueza que estaba proyectada para el
estado de tabasco mis papás se encaminan
y todas las veces que habían dicho mi
papá te vas a morir de hambre porque
había decidido estudiar ingeniero
petrolero esos te vas a morir de hambre
se convirtieron en contratos se
convirtieron en oportunidades de empleo
para nuevas personas se convirtieron en
sueños se convirtieron en casas se
convirtieron a nuevas familias y en una
compañía que abarcaba desde reynosa aquí
en tamaulipas hasta ciudad del carmen en
campeche casi cubríamos todo el golfo y
los fines de semana ni me llevaban a
ayudarle a mi papá a pagar a los
empleados porque no había depósito por
tarjeta era de pagarle la raya
pero qué sucedió 40 años después
la tecnología cambio el centro de
energía cambio y estamos dejando los
fósiles un poco de lado y estamos
buscando medios alternativos que no sean
tan agresivos con el medio ambiente y
hoy tabasco vive una de las peores
sequías y no precisamente de agua sino
energética que podamos imaginar los
despidos han sido masivos los cortes en
los centros de las paraestatales también
fueron masivas y las empresas que habían
llevado a cientos de y decenas de
familias a vivir a tabasco tuvieron que
dejar el lugar y esas personas ya se
habían encariñado el que yo joven se
casó tuvo una familia y ya tenía hijos y
no los podía dejar ahí y la pregunta que
nace después de saber de esta historia
es nos podrá pasar lo mismo
algo que no cambia es la palabra camino
y no creo que cambie en muchas décadas
vamos a seguir que tener el y eligiendo
vamos a seguir vamos a seguir eligiendo
carreras y profesiones eligiendo
vocaciones para la vida para el presente
para el futuro
algunos de ustedes ya eligieron una
carrera profesional que va a tener o no
va a tener tal vez una productividad en
un futuro oa lo mejor dentro de 20 años
no hay una niña o un niño que entran a
la primaria nos estamos formando para
que para trabajos que ni siquiera hoy
existen porque porque todo cambia y hay
que elegir un camino y esa etapa
yo creo que sacó esa decisión no va no
va a permanecer inmóvil por así decirlo
durante 100 o 200 años a lo mejor es
para siempre porque la época de confucio
confusio decía que elige una profesión
que ames y no tendrás que trabajar un
solo día de tu vida y en aquella época
comienza arroz sembradas arroz eras
guerrero era sacerdote o eras de la
realeza no había más donde solamente
habían cinco profesiones te decía que
eligiera su na que te hiciera feliz y
nunca tendrías que trabajar la agenda
del mundo no cambia el mundo tiene una
agenda tamaulipas tiene una agenda que
visualiza su futuro como la capital
energética y esa agenda sin precisamente
busca adaptarse a los recursos naturales
oa los recursos humanos o al capital
tal como lo escuchábamos pero algo que
no cambia es el destino que ya están
trazando porque visualizan un futuro
pero tenemos que entender que la visión
local la visión local de matamoros como
algo cercano de los parques eólicos o
cerca de donde se van a generar estos
estos grandes molinos de viento tiene
que ver con que esta visión local tiene
que compartirse con la visión personal
para que podamos tomar buenas decisiones
y esas decisiones personales están
centradas en cómo quiero ser feliz en
esta vida y esas decisiones de esa
visión local de los gobiernos locales
del gobierno de estatal del país entero
en el continente completo tienen que ver
con la visión zonas las personas visión
individual
y justamente allí es lo que
creo que es relevante para nuestro
estado que es relevante para nuestro
país se encuentra la visión de un modelo
educativo la visión de un modelo
educativo que no solamente vea el
conocimiento o adquirir capacidades o
adquirir competencias o adquirir
habilidades sino también poder
desarrollar nuevo conocimiento y también
incursionar en áreas diferentes por
ejemplo tenemos que pensar que la
expectativa de ser el estado de energía
contra la realidad están vinculadas por
un solo elemento y tiene que ver tiene
que ser la educación si nosotros
hablamos de futuro tenemos que hablar
acerca de educación como les decía hoy
un niño que está en el kinder y va a
estudiar algo va a estudiar su kinder su
primaria su secundaria y su preparatoria
y tal vez su universidad para un para un
empleo que hoy en día no existe y nos
estamos preparando para ese futuro de
qué se trata
se trata de visualizar esta tierra como
realmente debe ser como una tierra que
nosotros amemos y si no amamos esta
tierra tenemos que comprender que no
vamos a ver su futuro con respecto
con emoción y vamos a verlos verlos los
molinos de viento hacia arriba en vez de
verlo como una comunidad que se realiza
que no solamente de la robótica y que ve
la energía y que ve el medio ambiente
como un factor determinante para detonar
la economía sino que ve la energía y
estos molinos de viento a través del
cielo desde arriba con un país que ha
realizado y ha llevado a cabo sus sueños
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]